voici le quotidien de ludovic maillot
bleu blanc rouge après avoir nagé et
avant de courir il monte sur son vélo
pour 180 km dans le vendômois accompagné
par d'autres coureurs venus l'encourager
à ce train d'enfer
il a bien mérité une petite pause et du
soutien l'équipe médicale girex et le
sait le corps et puis tous les gens qui
suivent c'est la tête voilà ce et cce
mon moteur voilà je ne suis que l'argent
dont on va dire voilà c'est non c'est
sûr que ce serait beaucoup beaucoup
plusieurs ci est moins de monde voici
alain le médecin de ludovic ils
pratiquent un suivi quotidien du
triathlète et analyse des prises de sang
chaque semaine c'est lui qui aura le
dernier mot
c'était le deal de départ quand il m'a
proposé de le suivre dans cette aventure
je lui ai dit voilà une seule condition
c'est le jour où je dis stop tu cherches
même pas discuter tu te pose pas de
questions paraître et ça je lui fais
confiance et pour ça il n'y a pas de
problème donc
donc c'est vraiment c'était vraiment le
deal au départ pour le moins y'a pas
besoin j'espère qu'on n'aura pas besoin
depuis 14 jours le triathlète a suscité
des envies
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à nous
suivre sur le parcours et il n'y a pas
d'âge pour sa rencontre depuis 14 jours
des gens qui se remettent à couvrir qui
se remettent à sortir les vélos du
grenier enlever la poussière et venir
faire un tour avec
ça redonne envie à beaucoup de gens de
refaire du sport et ça c'est une belle
réussite message encouragements toute la
région de vendôme soutien à ludovic avec
ses allées et venues quotidienne c'est
devenu de l'attraction du pays
certains le salue tous les jours même si
ce n'est pas facile trop rapide 50 60 km
à 7,1 rapide mais en l'encourageant
l'encouragent en est là on est derrière
lui
voilà on se prend vite au jeu et on a
envie de le soutenir parce que comme il
dit si bien voilà c'est un défi qu'ils
partagent et on le ressent vraiment
quotidien il a toujours un petit
un p'tit sourire un p'tit mot agréable
pour les bénévoles donc c'est vraiment
très sympa du doman moitié homme moitié
robot a déjà battu le record du monde en
terminant aux courses ironman
consécutive samedi
il ne lui en reste plus que 27 à
parcourir